SOPHIA YANG: Hello, everyone.
Thank you so much
for being here today.
We are very excited to
see all of you here.
We are also very eager
to share with you
our perspectives about how to
better manage your VM instance.
My name is Sophia Yang, product
manager from the Compute Engine
team.
Joining me today are two of
my coworkers, [? Karen ?]
and [INAUDIBLE],, who will help
with some very awesome demos.
So let's get started.
When talking about running
workload on Compute Engine,
VM instances are really at the
heart and center of everything.
We want to make sure you
have the right instance
to run your job, but also,
you don't want to pay more.
And that's exactly
the first section
we're going to be
talking about, how
to tune a VM instance
so that you have
the best in price performance.
Next, we're talking
about scaling.
Most workloads are now done
with a single VM instance.
How can you scale
up and down quickly?
That is the second
section we'll be covering,
both the tools and the demo
to show you the performance
that we can achieve.
Third, backing up.
No critical
workloads can be done
without a good backup recovery
story, and in that section,
we have brand-new
features to share
with you to help you better
back up your VM instance.
And last but not least, secure.
How can you make sure
you can manage the access
control to your VM
instance so that your data,
your environment,
is all protected?
And at Google,
security and privacy
is always our first priority.
And there, we're going
to share with you
some tips and new
features about how
to better control the security
and to secure a VM instance.
First, let's talk about tuning.
Picking the right VM instance.
So if you are going to ask
me, what is the right VM
instance for me,
then I can't tell you
that, because I have
to ask you back,
what does your
workload look like?
The right answer is, the
VM instance size always
depends on workload.
So let's first look at
the popular workload
running today in cloud.
Here is just a list of them,
and the list goes on on and on.
Basically, at
Google, we understand
customers come with a
diverse set of workloads.
They all have a diverse
set of requirements.
And we are providing a
wider range of selection
of machine types
in the VM instance
and features to make sure we
can meet all your workload
requirements.
Here is just a overview
of the general categories
of the machine types we
are offering at Google.
We have general purpose, memory
optimized, and shared cores.
Within each family, we also
allow great flexibility
so that you don't have to think
too much on the constraints
in terms of what you
should do in order
to utilize certain features.
What do I mean by that?
For example, let's dive into
the general purpose machine
types, which is our most
popular machine type.
Within a general purpose
pool, we have three families--
standard, high
memory and high CPU.
They are really designed to
be suitable for a majority
of your workloads.
So if you have
the web server you
are trying to host, the CI/CD
workload you are trying to run,
chances are you
can find the best
suited machine within this
general purpose machine type.
They're highly available
across all regions and zones,
and just remember, I
mentioned that they
are very flexible to use.
For example, you can attach
local SSDs and the GPUs
to all of them.
And like at other
cloud providers,
you have to think
about what size
and what generations do
I have to use in order
to, for example, use GPUs.
At Google, general
purpose machine types,
you can attach GPUs and
local SSDs to all of them.
Better than that, we also
allowed a wider range of core
to GPU ratios.
For example, at
Google, if you only
need a 1 core VM to
do a job, but you
would like to have 4 GPUs to
have better parallel computing,
you can do that combination.
But not unlike other
cloud providers,
you have to have a much bigger
VM in order to have 4 GPUs.
Within the predefined
families, all the machines
come with 1, 2 4, all
the way up to 96 cores.
So the next very
natural question
will be, say I picked
the 8 core machine.
How can I make
sure I'm maximizing
all the compute power?
How can I make
sure I'm utilizing
all the money I'm spending?
And that is an
excellent question.
In fact, RightScale recently
did a study showing the estimate
about 35% of cloud
spending is all wasted.
Why waste it?
Just as an example, I mentioned
you have a 8 core machine,
right, but your
workload actually
probably only needs 6 cores,
so there's 2 cores wasted.
Another more extreme example,
what if your workload needs,
say, 18 cores.
So a 16 core machine
wouldn't be enough,
while the next in line
if you need to jump to
will be 32 cores.
So that will be almost double
the compute power you need.
So what are your options there?
You can, one, pay
double the money
so that you have the
maximum performance,
or you rewrite your
code, the architecture,
so that, you know,
your workload run
could fit in better
in the 16 cores.
None of them ideal
options, right?
And in fact, all
the cloud providers
know that not all the
predefined machine sizes
can fit all the workloads best.
But why haven't they
done anything yet?
The truth is, the cores
that you are now using,
that's great news for
the cloud provider,
because they can then sell
that to other people, right?
But at Google, it's different.
We want you to get
exactly what you
need without paying any
more, and that is why
we offer custom machine types.
As the name suggests,
you can customize
a number of cores
and memories exactly
as you want with all the
flexibility you want.
With custom machine types, you
can even achieve higher memory
to CPU ratio compared to
general purpose machines.
This is a great use case
if you have certain, say,
licensing requirements, if
your OIs or [? application ?]
providers, say, are charging
you based on the number of cores
you have.
So you want to kind of
be conservative there,
but you also want a
large amount of memory
to maximize your
workload performance.
And you can do that
with extended memory
within the custom
machine type family.
To get started with custom
machine types, it's very easy.
Just define the number
of cores and memories
you need as that example
shows on the screen.
In this example,
you create a new VM
with a custom machine type.
You can also updating
existing machines
to a newer VM shape, which
is based off in a VM first.
As mentioned, general
purpose machine types
is the most popular
machine types
at Google, plus the
custom machine type.
They should be able to
achieve the performance you
want with most of your
workload requirements.
And in fact, more than
99% of our customers
today are running on
these custom machine
types plus the general
purpose machine types.
And next, let's see
some other options
and features you might utilize
to maximize your workload
performance.
The next one I want to touch
about is the preemptible VMs.
What they are, they're really
just short-lived, low-cost VMs.
How short-lived?
They can only run
up to 24 hours.
And that is if not Google
preempted you before that.
Google might preempt your VMs
at any time with 30 seconds'
notification, so
your workload better
be pretty robust so that you can
handle that kind of preemption.
And what is the plus side?
The price.
You can save up to 80%
compared to the listing
price for regular VMs.
Another very powerful
thing to realize,
you can make any machine
types available at Google
as preemptible VMs.
You can just change a setting or
property within a VM instance,
make it a preemptible,
and there you have it.
They're really
suited for, say you
have a fault-tolerant workload
as a batch job, or media
rendering, genomic kind of
jobs or short-lived jobs.
They are not very
suitable if you
have a job that you
have a certain deadline,
say, in the next hour, you
want to run a business report,
we don't recommend you
run preemptible VMs.
Next, memory optimized VMs.
We know a lot of enterprises,
probably many of you sit here,
you're in the process of
migrating your workload
from your data center to cloud.
We realize one of the
biggest challenges
to move those large
in-memory databases,
like SAP HANA, a lot of times
because they couldn't find
a suitable hardware on cloud
that can run your big memory
machines, customers
are forced to set up
this hybrid environment,
because they already
moved their applications,
web service onto the cloud.
Yet, they have to leave their
memory optimized VM behind
because they just couldn't
find the right thing in cloud.
Well, if you are one
of those customers,
you'll be happy to find
out that Google offers
the memory optimized VMs,
which can provide you up
to 3.8 terabyte memories.
That is a lot of memories.
Within the memory optimized
VMs we have four machine types,
as you can see.
And you can achieve as high
as 24 gigabytes per CPO ratio.
And you might be thinking, oh,
these must be very expensive.
Well, they probably are more
expensive than the share
cores or one core VM.
But if you look at it
a price per gig ratio,
they are actually the cheapest
among all of machine types.
So they're also
very cost-effective.
So if you're one
of those customers
you have a big, you
know, memory database
like SAP HANA
[INAUDIBLE],, now you never
have to leave them behind while
move all the workload on cloud.
So go ahead and try those
memory optimized VMs.
And if you missed the
news from last week,
we're happy to remind
you that we just
made these memory
optimized VMs to be
generally available for you.
Well, after talking about
memory intensive workload,
let's talk about compute
intensive workload.
Last February, also
at Next, Google
announced the
general availability
of Skylake CPUs, which made
us the first ever cloud
provider support the
latest Intel processor.
Skylake benchmark shows if we
enable the advanced instruction
ABX 512, it can double the
floating point calculation
compared to the
previous generation.
So it's powerful if you have
a high compute intensive
workload.
They are perfect for scientific
modeling, 3D rendering.
And in order to utilize
the Skylake CPU,
you can utilize our mean CPU
platform selector function
within a VM instance.
As the example
shows, you can just
define, say, mean CPU platform
equals to Intel Skylake.
Then Google will make
sure your VM will land
on a hardware that has Skylake.
Or even later generations
when they are available.
All right, since we were talking
about use cases of customers,
we have seen in other
common cases is that--
especially from certain
verticals or industries
like finance, health
care, the customers
have regulations to
meet in terms of where
they can place the VM instance.
And if you are one
of those customers,
you'll be happy
to find out Google
offers sole tenant nodes, which
are physical servers dedicated
solely for you to use.
So different from
regular VMs where
you have to share the physical
host with other customers.
You can achieve
performance isolation
as you have this whole server
dedicated just for you.
To get started,
it's very simple.
Just create a sole tenant
group using the template.
And then you can
schedule VM instances
onto those sole tenant groups.
In terms of where the
VM will be placed,
we have great flexibility
offered there too.
So you can obviously
directly explicitly tell us
where the group
you want to target.
Or you can use labels
and label selectors.
So you know to utilize that.
You will first define
labels for those group.
And you can have multiple
labels for each group.
And then when you're
scheduling the VMs,
you are targeting those labels.
You can say, place
this VM on a group
that the environment
equals to test
and the team equals
A. And Google
will find the best place for you
that meets both requirements.
Or you can use anti-affinity.
You can say, place this
VM in a group of A,
but environment does
not equal to production.
So you achieve both
anti-affinity and affinity
with our labels design, which
is very unique and flexible
offering.
Last point I want to
mention about sole tenants
is you can also mix
different shapes of VMS
onto the same host.
Again, at Google we always
think about your need.
We want to give you
the max flexibility,
also allowing you
to best utilize
all the resources you got
without any artificial
constraints.
What is making it better?
Today we'll let you know
that the sole tenant
node's going to be generally
available for you in August.
That's really just next month.
All right, we have talk quite
a bit about different VM
types, machine
types, and features
you can utilize between
other to best achieve
your price performance.
So I want to make sure you
guys are still with me.
So here's a quick
overview of the things
we are already talking about.
And actually, I would like to
ask the audience some questions
since we're all so close.
Just making sure you
were paying attention.
So given the same
machine type, which
one saves you the most money?
Great.
Yeah, preemptible VMs.
Let's say, what if
you have SAP HANA,
what machine probably
the best for you?
Memory optimized, great.
Let's try our last one.
What if I, say you
don't want your--
you want to schedule VM to
somewhere that you don't
have neighbors you don't know.
Great, which is going to be
generally available for you
next month.
All right, next let's move
on to the second point--
scaling.
Most people here don't
just want one single VM.
How can we quickly
scale up and down
so that it guess
your workload then?
We're going to cover
that in this section.
We're going to
first tell you two
tools that you can utilize and
then have a great demo for you.
So first let's talk about
the two tools you can use.
Earlier this year,
we made this feature
available for you that is about
creating individual instances
from a templates.
This allowing you
two great use cases.
One is you don't have to create
a VM instance from scratch
anymore.
So what you can do is,
you can create a template.
You know, define all the
images you want to use.
You know, [INAUDIBLE] et cetera.
And then quickly duplicate
the VMs from there.
Another use case,
we have actually
learned this from IT
elements, that they often
want to issue some
recommended shapes of the VMs
to their developers.
Using the approved
image they want,
you know, using these kind
of subnets or firewall rules
they want.
So how to kind of pass down
this requirement easily?
They can create those
instant template
so that the [INAUDIBLE]
person know exactly where they
should start.
Another thing to
mention, if needed,
you too can override
the properties
within that instant template
when you are creating this VM.
So again, great flexibility.
For example, in the
example in the screen,
you're providing a
source instant template.
Yet you're overriding
the metadata value
to be a new value.
So that is to achieve
exactly what you want.
Next, if you prefer Google
to manage the group of VMs
for you to scaling
up and down for you,
then you can utilize our
managed instance group offering.
There are two modes you can use.
One is fixed size.
Say you define 100
of VMs in our group.
And Google will make sure
we made the 100 for you
and do the health check if we
realize any VM's unhealthy.
You can take them down and
bring up a new one for you.
Another mode is
auto-scaling mode.
You can most likely connect
that to a load balancer,
and then we can scale up and
down, based on your traffic.
An original fill over because
we support both zonal managed
instance group and regional.
So if if you're utilizing
regional managed instance
group, it kind of
widens some zone outage.
And and if you want to learn
more about this managed
instance group, there's a
session tomorrow for you
that you can attend.
This is going to be delivered
by my coworker, [? Micola. ?]
All right, so as we talk
about the features used
to help you scale
up and down, I think
another common concern
from customers will be,
wow, I have to scale up and
now this many VMs very quickly.
So what kind of performance
Google can deliver?
And if you are one of--
you are the the customer
had that kind of question,
you'll be happy
to find out Google
has excellent
performance, especially
in terms of bringing up VMs.
A group of them.
As Gartner said it, Google
has exceptional fast VM
provisioning time.
Also, here's another quote
from our customer, saying,
they think--
and we think, too--
Google is the best
cloud platform
because the great stability
and the performance.
All right, so we
have analyzed report.
You know, customer
approved my point.
But what is making it
even more convincing?
Wouldn't you want to
see how quickly we
can bring up VMs in real life?
So today I would like to invite
my coworker [? Karen ?] here
to give you a live demo to show
you how quickly we can bring up
VMs up and down.
KAREN: Thank you, Sophia.
Thank you.
SOPHIA YANG: All right,
let's switch the demo source.
[? KAREN: ?] OK.
So for the demo we have
prepared instance template
that specifies general
machine type with one core.
And we created a
managed instance group
in Europe, the European zone.
And we're going to scale this
managed instance group up
to say, 50.
SOPHIA YANG: 50?
[? KAREN: ?] 50 VMs.
SOPHIA YANG: Do you
want to see more?
[? KAREN: ?] Let's try 100.
SOPHIA YANG: OK.
And now go to the website.
[? KAREN: ?] So
this is the console
for managing the
instance groups.
And we're going to update the
existing instance template
and change the number
of instances to be 100.
And the VMs that are going to
start up, they have an imagine
and have a startup
script that as soon
as they come up and boot,
they will ping the web
servers that we deployed.
And the web servers
will visualize the
SOPHIA YANG: The
master node of the--
[? KAREN: ?] The VMs
that are coming up.
So this is the web service that
detected that instance group is
scaling up.
And it times up--
calculates the time it takes to
receive messages from the slave
nodes as it receives them.
So during this
period, the VMs are
allocating computer resources--
IP addresses.
And they are being booted,
programmed to the network,
and then they start
pinging the web service.
And as you can see,
waiting, like, 40 seconds,
we've got all the VMs
started, booted, and running
the customer workload,
which in this case
is pinging the master node.
SOPHIA YANG: Wow, 41 seconds.
100 nodes.
[APPLAUSE]
I feel the longest wait is
actually the VM provisioning
time, where, as you mentioned,
allocating IPs, et cetera.
[? KAREN: ?] True.
I think the demo was faster
than we usually have seen,
but this is--
SOPHIA YANG: Don't
tell them that.
[? KAREN: ?] Maybe we
can try something bigger
and spend up more VMs.
Like, go higher number.
SOPHIA YANG: How you
guys want to see them?
[INAUDIBLE]
1000?
Did I hear 1,000?
10,000?
Should we put 10,000 load
onto our production system?
[? KAREN: ?] We
can do that, but it
will probably take a little
bit longer and bore you guys.
So let's try the 1,000.
SOPHIA YANG: Sure, but before
you start, let's have a guess.
Well, 100 is 41 seconds.
So how long should 1,000 be?
[INAUDIBLE]
People are good at math, right?
Well, let's see if we can do
better than linear scaling.
By the way, that's the
right answer, I think--
41 times 10.
[? KAREN: ?] OK, so
the instance group
is now scaling up to
1,000 VMs and we already
see the VMs showing up in
the managed instance group,
and see what their
web service is.
SOPHIA YANG: So the count
already started and we're
trying to see if we can--
[? KAREN: ?] Yeah,
the timer is started,
but we already have the 100
VMs from the previous action.
So we're going to wait
for another 900 VMs.
SOPHIA YANG: Well,
I already see VM
starts coming in as we speak.
SPEAKER 1: Can I ask a
question while we're waiting?
[? KAREN: ?] Sure.
SPEAKER 1: What is a
health check [INAUDIBLE]??
[? KAREN: ?] The VMs that are
already running the customer
workload, they ping
the master node,
so that's the custom startup
script that the VMs use.
And that's how we detect
that the VM is already
up and running the user code.
SOPHIA YANG: Well, the
number quick is going up.
Already 400.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
It's real demo.
A live demo.
[? KAREN: ?] This is real demo.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE] They're
coming up faster [INAUDIBLE]
first time.
[? KAREN: ?] Yeah,
because this depends
how busy the cluster is.
So there is also other
customer workloads
running in European zone
that we are accessing.
SOPHIA YANG: Yeah, we
have customers in Europe.
A lot of them.
This shows our compute
power [INAUDIBLE]..
People don't stop computing.
And great, I think it is done.
[? KAREN: ?] So, like, less
than two minutes to provision
1,000 of VMs.
SOPHIA YANG: A lot faster
than the 400 seconds, right?
[? KAREN: ?] Yeah.
SOPHIA YANG: That is
so awesome to see.
[? KAREN: ?] So it's important
to provision the VMs fast.
It's also important
for the workloads
to de-provision the VMs.
And that's usually
in the scenarios
here where you want to
update your cluster,
tear down the existing
VMs and start new ones.
So we would like to also
demonstrate the de-provisioning
and deleting the VMs.
So I'll go ahead and remove all
the VMs from my instance group,
resize it to zero.
And in this case, I'm
not going to look just
to shut down script of the
VMs because the first thing
that we do in GC, we
stop the [INAUDIBLE]
from running user code,
but then it takes some more
time until we're released
all the computer sources,
IP addresses, and delete the
resources from our database.
So what the service does,
it monitors all the VMs
in managed systems
group and make sure
they are fully deleted before
it showing as teared down
in this visualization.
So, like, if we go on this page,
you will see some of the VMs
are being deleted and they
probably already stopped
running the workload, but
we still have them here.
We already got several
of the VMs deleted,
but it will take
a little bit more
time to tear down all of them.
SOPHIA YANG: Well, we
can see VMs are already
start getting down.
And I think what--
in addition to what you
mentioned in the use case,
like CICDs or updates that
you want to kind of quickly
tear down your cluster so that
you can start the next one.
Also, I want to
remind you, you don't
start paying until the VMs
are stopped or deleted.
So being able to do so quickly
for a large amount of VMs also
saves you a lot of money.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
So the question is, when
we're deleting them,
do we have an undo option to
cache them for a little bit?
[? KAREN: ?] No,
when you delete,
they are permanently deleted.
Like, if you delete
the VM, their disks
are not necessarily deleted.
It's an option that
you can specify
and we can delete just the VM,
but the disks will stay longer.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
[? KAREN: ?] Yes.
And I think--
SOPHIA YANG: Well,
we're almost done.
All right, only six
left and it seems
like a little over two minutes.
[? KAREN: ?] Yeah,
I think deletion
took a little longer
than that two minutes
we got for the creation.
SOPHIA YANG: All right,
it's almost done.
I think the next, I refresh.
Great.
Oh, still seven.
[? KAREN: ?] I think
it's OK to skip those.
Yeah, so I think if
you try to tear down
existing cluster and then
provision that from scratch, it
will take you less
than five minutes
to do that with 1,000 VMs.
SOPHIA YANG: Great,
thank you so much.
[? KAREN: ?] Thank
you, everyone.
SOPHIA YANG: Isn't that amazing?
Thank you so much, [? Karen. ?]
And I think I forgot
to mention, [? Karen's ?] one of
our technical lead to make all
of this possible, to make this
spinning up and down possible
quickly.
Thank you.
All right, so can we switch
back to the presentation?
All right.
So next, let's talk
about backing up.
As mentioned, no matter
you have this database,
all share the file
system, whatever
the important workload, you want
to have a great backup story,
to periodically back up
the data to make sure
you have a great
checkpoint to go back.
So in this section,
we're going to tell you
two tools you can use to better
back up your VM instance.
The first one is to use
Instance Template, which
is similar as what
we attached earlier.
We mentioned about using
template create multiple VMs.
And in this case,
you can also use
the other, which is
creating instant template
from the existing VM.
Why this is useful, because
we have heard of many,
the use cases especially,
so a developer
trying to prototype
something starting off
from a new project.
They often start with
a VM and then tweak it
to exactly where they want it.
Maybe add the disk.
You know, maybe change
the network, et cetera.
So once they're are
done to tweak it
to exact the golden state,
they might not actually
need a VM, you know,
because of prototyping,
but they want to make sure
they save the configuration so
that they can go back
to recreate that.
And if you have that
kind of requirement,
you can generate a instant
template from the VM.
To use the instant
template is almost
like the configuration
of the time
machine of the
configuration of your VM,
so they can go back at any time,
without paying any extra money,
as the VM is already deleted.
To get started is also simple.
As the example shows
on G Cloud, you
can just simply provide
a source instance
while you're creating
the instant template.
So this is another
great tool to know
how to save your configuration
of your VM instance.
And next, obviously, we were
talking about backing up,
but the most important
thing is to back up
your data on the disk.
You probably know
about a snapshot.
We already provide that feature
and that's a great feature.
A very high-performance
and space-efficient
offering that Google
already offered.
But you might want to ask, how
can I periodically generating
snapshots?
Well, without any help from
Google, you can use a cron job,
but customers have
been telling us
it's a pain to manage,
especially without including
deletion or how to manage that.
And if you are one
of those customers,
you'll be really
happy to find out
Google now will offer you to
schedule the snapshot feature.
What this does is exactly
meant to replace your cron job.
What a scheduled snapshot
support is will support
the frequency of creation
snapshots would be hour-, day-,
and week-based, and will
also support retention policy
as the number of days you
want to keep the snapshot.
So you can simply create
a schedule looks like,
create me a daily snapshot
and then delete after 14 days.
Very flexible to use.
You can create a schedule and
then attach to multiple disk
so that you don't
have to do that again
and again on every disk.
One thing to call out--
the snapshots created the
same as regular snapshots.
They are incremental snapshots.
Sometimes people call
differential snapshots.
What this does is it
only takes a snapshot
of the delta of the change
between the end time and plus
one.
So you have a very
minimal change
or if no change between the
two times, your snapshot set
is going to be very small.
So you are not paying
the whole disk size.
So very space-efficient,
high-performance,
and also price-efficient.
And you will be very
excited to find out
the this feature going to be
available for you for beta
very soon.
So next, I would like to invite
my coworker [INAUDIBLE] here.
Also, the lead engineer to who
made this feature possible,
to give you a quick
step-by-step guide on how
to create scheduled snapshot.
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: Hi.
Thanks, Sophia.
As Sophia mentioned, now taking
periodic backup of your disk
has been made really easy.
All you need to do are
two steps using G Cloud.
First is to create a schedule
in which you specify a start
time that tells us the time
of the day at which you
want the snapshots of
the disks to be taken.
And then specify the
frequency for those snapshots.
And as Sophia mentioned,
it could be hourly.
Like, every hour,
every 12 hours.
It could be daily,
or it could be
just certain days of the week.
And once you create
the schedule,
we also need to specify some
retention with max retention
days so that we know how long
to keep your snapshots for.
And after those many days, we
automatically clean them off
for you.
Once the schedule
is created, you
can add it to one on multiple
disks within the region.
And it can be done
on an existing disk
or it can be done while you
are creating your disk itself.
So since these snapshots are
created as per the schedule,
so I can't demo this thing
instantly like [? Karen ?] did.
But for the demo purposes, I
have created two set schedules.
And [INAUDIBLE].
So one is hourly with
two days of retention
and another one is daily
with three days of retention,
as you see.
Here I specify the start
time to be 12:00 PM.
And let's see how the generated
snapshots are looking.
And I created this schedule
just a few days back.
Like, four days back.
Can you switch to
the demo, please?
SOPHIA YANG: I think
it's the second tab.
SPEAKER 1: So here,
let me just filter
by the disk with
the daily schedule.
And here we see exactly
three snapshots,
as my retention was three
and my frequency was daily.
If I go into the details
of the snapshots,
I see the name itself
has the name of the disk.
The name of the zone
where the disk resides.
And also, the time stamp
so that it's easy for you
to read and know when
the snapshot was created.
And as we see, the time
matches exactly 12:00 PM.
Somewhere around 12:00 PM, as it
takes a few seconds to actually
finish uploading the snapshot.
And as we go back,
as Sophia mentioned,
our snapshots are incremental.
I didn't change anything in
those disks for last three
days.
So on my first, the
oldest snapshot,
is a non-empty snapshot
and others are empty.
And you will not be charged
for the empty snapshots.
So basically, you'll
not be charged just
for creating the
periodic snapshot.
Instead, you'll be charged
for only the change
that you make to your disk.
And let's now filter by the
disk with an hourly schedule.
And here you see a
lot more snapshots
because these are being
created every hour,
as you see by the name.
And none of these
snapshots are old.
The oldest snapshot
is also two days old,
because I had specified the
retention to be two days.
I hope this feature helps you
to manage your backups much
better.
And thanks, Sophia.
SOPHIA YANG: Thank
you, [INAUDIBLE]..
Great feature.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, let's switch
back to the present.
Great.
So last point I want to talk
about involves security.
How is your secured
access to a VM instance?
How can you protect
the environment?
So there are three
things that we would like
to introduce in that section.
The first thing is the famous
Identity and Access Management,
or so-called IAM.
For the few people that
don't know what IAM is,
I will just give you
a quick crash course.
IAM is about defining who can do
which actions on what resource.
So that's abstract, right?
Let's just have an example.
So you could assign me,
Sophia, the instance admin role
onto your test project.
That's going to allow me
to manipulate and manage
your instances in
your test project.
But you did not give me the same
permission to your production
project.
So I wouldn't be able to do
so on the production project.
So that's kind of fine
control on access control.
So with the newly released
resource-level IAM feature, now
you are able to
assign IAM policies
on individual resources
like VMs, disks.
Well, this allowing you to
say common use case will be.
I have one instance I would
like to collaborate with you,
troubleshoot with you.
But I don't want to share
everything else in the project
with you.
So I don't want to set
a policy on a project.
Instead, I want to set IAM
policy on the instance.
And you can achieve
this by simply,
as the example command
shows on the screen,
you can set IAM policy
on a particular instance.
And I will have the
full access to it.
With that, I would
like to also give
you guys a quick demo on how
this resource level IAM work.
And by the way,
this feature is also
going to be available
for beta very soon.
Can we switch to
demo real quick?
So for this demo purpose, I am
using a demo account I created.
And this is myself, who is the
owner have all the power to do
everything in the project.
And I put another
test account, which
is David, who also is
looking at my project.
But you can see the difference.
As a project owner,
I can manipulate
all the instances [INAUDIBLE]
to start or stop them.
Yet David, as just a
viewer of the project,
he's not allowed to--
as you can see, he is not
allowed to stop a VM instance
or start.
He doesn't have the permission.
He cannot also SSH into it.
Again, no permission, right?
Say there is a situation arises.
I do need now David to be
able to access into my machine
to help me
troubleshoot something.
I can go ahead and set a
policy on the particular VM
and just copy his username.
Well, great.
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
And I copy his name.
And I will go ahead
into my console.
My view, which I am the
owner of the project.
I can go ahead set
the permission,
which is opening the side panel
and adding the member of him
and giving him the permission
of say, instance admin role.
And add.
Simply by doing so, I'm
giving him the permission
to the particular
instance that was 11.
So let's go back to his view.
Let's refresh this console.
And now you can see this
particular instance 11,
he has [INAUDIBLE] and
he has the permission
to stop or suspend
the VM instance.
So that's the
resource-level IAM policy
going to be available
for you beta very soon.
Let's move back to
the presentation.
And next I want to
mention is about how
to protect your
operating system.
How to prevent
people that are not
authorized to be able to
access into a machine?
And that is OS
Login is a feature
you have to learn there.
So before the OS Login
feature available,
the world was like, the
only way to log in on VM
is through setting the
SSH key IAM VM instance
metadata or the metadata
on the project level.
The problem is that is, as
soon as the SSH key is set,
there is no connection
whatsoever with the SSH
key versus the user.
So that's making
managing the access
or revoking keys very
difficult. So this employee
could have already
left your company,
but as long as he still knows
the key value [? pair ?] on SSH
key, he can potentially
still log in
to your production, environment.
And that expose a
lot of risk to you.
With OS Login, we made a strong
connection between the SSH key
and the user identity,
which IAM control.
So that user no longer logging
in by just the metadata
set on the SSH keys.
Instead, the user will log
in with their own identity.
With OS Login we have
two roles available.
IAM roles available
to assign to users.
OS Login, which is the normal,
non-root access kind of user.
And OS Admin log in,
obviously, offers root access.
But no matter which role
the user is assigned to,
they will never log in as root.
They always log
in as themselves.
So that is also making
auditing very easy later on.
And we also offer Admin
SDK Directory API,
which allowing the admins
to manage and set those SSH
keys on behalf of users.
So OS Login, great feature to
manage your operating system
access.
And the very last
feature I would
like to share with you to help
with better access control,
is organizational
policy, Org Policy.
Org Policy is really designed
to work side by side with IAM.
But the key
difference between IAM
is Org Policy has the
enforcement, regardless
this IAM access.
For example, we have the first
one, No External IP Org Policy.
Say if you set Org Policy
on to the org level
and set deny to all
the VM instances that
can now create its own IP.
So then even your security
admin, the computer admin,
who should have the IAM
permission to create
external IP, will
not be able to do so.
Again, because the enforcement
is there regardless
of IAM permission.
So that enables you to
prevent human error.
Also, enable you to prevent
certain internal malicious
user.
Of course, we hope you
don't have any of those.
And there are a couple more
Org Policies you can utilize.
You can set VM
instance, trusted image.
Make sure you limit what
images developers can use.
You want to make sure they
only use supported versions.
Disable serial port access.
Again, to protect
your OS system so
that no sensitive information
can get out from the serial
console.
All right, with that let's
have a quick review of what
we have talked so far.
Tuning a instance, scaling,
backup, and secure.
And if there's one message
we wanted you to take away
from this talk and
that is, Google
offers a wider range
of machine types
and features to meet all your
workload requirement need.
Well, without any
artificial constraints
and without paying anymore.
And if you want to learn
more about a compute engine,
there are upcoming sessions
you can tend to just tomorrow
and Thursday,
especially if you want
to learn more about security
and the privacy and IAM,
I have another session
Thursday at 1:15.
[MUSIC PLAYING]